So, what's the way forward after the murder of George Floyd?
That's the question I'd like to get into today.
My name is Brett Silford, pastor at The Table, a church in Sac State, Texas, and welcome
to Table Talk, where each week I unpack ideas and insights at the intersection of Christian
theology and culture.
Alright, let's get into our conversation today.
So nearly all of you have seen the video of George Floyd being brutally murdered by the
white police officer, and it rightly sparked outrage across the political spectrum.
It was a disgusting act of systemic racism.
Now why do I say systemic and not simply racism?
Because as a uniformed officer, he is part of a broader culture, a system, a network
that too often is engaged in acts like this.
And now, somewhat predictably, the peaceful protests have, by a much smaller subset of
people, at times turned violent, though honestly I'm really only shocked that the violence
hasn't been worse.
And I should also add, it's not entirely clear who exactly is instigating the violence.
Now having said that, the question is where do we go from here?
So I thought Van Jones, from CNN, summed it up really beautifully when he said, and here
I'm going to paraphrase, we get to choose whether this summer we're going to have a
breakthrough or a breakdown.
He said, if we get bipartisan police reform and have these four officers charged, then
we'll get a breakthrough.
If not, we're one video away from civil unrest and a breakdown.
So what does Van Jones mean by police reform?
Well he's advocating for the implementation of practices and procedures done in places
all across the country, but in a place, for example, like Richmond, California, has been
a great success story.
So according to richmondpulse.org, there's a story there that I'll link to, that in Richmond,
the police chief there has done a number of different things, right, because it's not
just one thing.
He has shifted the emphasis from an enforcement-driven, military-style kind of ethos and culture that
says we're going to eradicate crime by ratcheting up the level of force that we use, to one
that says we're going to begin building as much trust with our community as possible,
especially the non-white community, because their trust is basically gone.
In the words of police chief Chris Magnus, quote, the biggest challenge has been changing
the perception black community members have toward the police, those who have experienced
a legacy of mistrust.
So how did this police chief, how did he do this?
Well it wasn't, of course, as I said, just one thing.
It was a number of things.
He began promoting officers based on merit and performance rather than relational connections
or simply seniority.
It meant he demoted and fired more officers in his short tenure than in the last 20 years
combined.
It meant having the police officers assigned to specific neighborhoods for their careers
so they could form long-term relationships with the people there and develop a reputation,
right, become known, as opposed to rotating through different areas each year.
It meant the officers became a fixture at city meetings, neighborhood events, volunteer
opportunities.
It meant doing less time in the police cruiser, more time walking around, meeting people.
In fact, an officer named Yesenia Rogers, who was part of this department in Richmond
undergoing these reforms, she actually chose to give her personal cell number to business
owners, to residents, so they could contact her if they saw any illegal activity.
And finally, it meant intentionally shifting from older-style force to preventative policing
and verbal de-escalating, which has led to a strong decrease in the use of handcuffs,
batons, guns, etc.
Resident and volunteer Benny Louie Singleton, she said that she used to be afraid to even
drive down certain streets, that she now walks without fear.
And this is her quote, this is all because the community has started interacting with
police and vice versa.
I've never been so comfortable with police, she said.
It's like everything else, when you get to know a person, you look at them differently.
So it's changes like these, and many others, that we have to begin implementing to change
the culture in policing, so that deaths like Floyd's become a thing of the past.
And I suspect that these and other changes that increase the level of police accountability
are efforts that the majority of officers who are simply trying to keep their communities
safe would welcome.
Things like transparency, trust, and accountability, of course, have to become the new normal.
Now, you might say that these protests aren't necessary, they're just causing trouble, they're
all for nothing.
I don't think that's accurate at all.
The purpose of protests is pressure and attention.
It's keeping a thing in front of us and in front of our leaders long enough to do something
about it.
So to read more about police reform in Richmond, like I said, I'll link that article below
and it will give you more of the story.
But that's kind of the call to action, I guess.
Like Van Jones said, we have a decision before us, breakthrough or breakdown, and I'm pushing
for a breakthrough, and I hope you'll join me.
So that's all for today.
If you enjoyed this video, please share it, comment below, and to ensure you don't miss
future episodes, you can subscribe to my YouTube channel or podcast by searching Brett Tilford
TableTalk.
Grace and peace.